hey dub Walker here doing a shout out
for two cons are coming up a one is
anime Iowa that's in coralville July 29
to the 31st and there's going to be all
sorts of great people there a spike
Spencer is gonna be there Stephen blooms
gonna be there of course I'm gonna be
there Malcolm attempt are gonna be there
all sorts of great people definitely
check that out and the second one is fan
world this is for my Canadian fans this
is all around niagara falls and it's
august 26 to the 28th man to many great
people to count coming to this one of
course I'm gonna be there james rolfe is
gonna be there brad jones is gonna be
there Malcolm and Tamara are gonna be
there dante basco is going to be there
just so many great people these are all
phenomenal guests and you're gonna have
a great time so definitely check the
links below see if you can get to those
that love to say hi to you guys and
hopefully I'll see you there later